صيف 2022 بمقر النيتو في بروكسل فنلندا
والسويد تتقدمان بطلب العضويه في حلف شمال
الاطلسي كان الاعتقاد حينها ان عمليه
الانضمام للحلف ستمضي دون عقبات
البلدين اللذان ظل على الحياد منذ انشاء
الحلف قبل سبعه عقود قرر في حمئه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وما تلاها من
تداعيات تغيير موقفهما فنلندا الجاره
المباشره لروسيا رات في الامر ضروره ملحه
نقدر كثيرا دعم الحلف لعضويه فنلندا
ونتطلع الى عمليه التصديق السريعه لن
تساهم عضويه كل من فنلندا والسويد في
تعزيز امننا فحسب بل الامن الجماعي للحلف
ان مفهوم الاستراتيجيه الذي تم قبوله في
مدريد سيزيد الامن والاستقرار في اوروبا
لكن بعد عشره اشهر يظل قرار ضم البلدين
للحلف
رهنا بموقف انقره المطالبه بشروط ترى
هيلسنكي وستوكهولم انه تم استيفاؤها قناعه
يتقاسمها امين عام الحلف الذي حث على
تسريع اليات الضم قبل قمه الحلف المقرره
صيف العام الجاري
لقد حان الوقت للموافقه على انضمام فنلندا
والسويد للحلف لقد قطعت خطوات كبيره منذ
توقيعنا على التصريح المشترك معهما ومع
تركيا في قمه النيتو بمدريد العام الماضي
لقد رفعت الدولتان القيود عن صادره
الاسلحه وعززه تشريعاتهما بشان الارهاب
كما تقوم السويد بتعديل دستورها وبدات
تنفيذ اليه لمواصله العمل ايضا مع تركيا
في مكافحه الارهاب على وقع الحرب عزز
الحلف جبهته الشرقيه من خلال انشاء
مجموعات قتاليه في بلغاريا واستونيا
والمجر واللادفيا وليتوانيا وبولندا
ورومانيا وسلوفاكيا كما ارسل مزيدا من
السفن والطائرات والقوات الى الجناح
الشرقي للنيتو من بحر البلطيق في الشمال
الى البحر الاسود في الجنوب
وبينما يتمدد الحلف شرقا تتطلع دول
البلقان وجورجيا ومولدوفا الى دعم النيتو
في مواجهه الضغوط الروسيه فيما يبدو سعيا
لتلافي تكرار سيناريو اوكرانيا هي اعاده
رسم لحدود ظل الحلف يحافظ عليها منذ نهايه
الحرب البارده لكنه بدا يتخطاها كما تقول
روسيا على نحو متسارع يمر الانضمام الى
النيتو بمسار طويل لكثير من الدول تقطيه
بين الوعود والافعال يبدو ان طريق السويد
وفنلندا اقصر لكنه ضبابي يمر بحسابات
سياسيه اضافه الى العسكريه عبد الله
الشامي الجزيره بروكسيل